I'm in El Paso Texas outside the Sacred
Heart Catholic Church just across the
border from ciudad Juarez officials here
in El Paso estimate as many as 2500
people have built an encampment in and
around this neighborhood primarily
around this church seeking Refuge this
is
it was
the migrant population has surged in
advance of the end of title 42 the
public health law that has allowed the
Trump Administration and now the Biden
Administration to quickly expelled many
migrants who have crossed the border
illegally before they can ask for
Protections in the U.S some of these
migrants an Untold number actually
crossed the border without encountering
Federal immigration officials and are
without papers at this point
I am declaring a state of emergency in
our community and the reason why we're
declaring the state of emergency is to
make sure that we can stand up and be
prepared for May 11 May 12th to have
public Sheltering public housing rumors
are camping across the bordering
sea.plate as according to local
officials here that if you can make it
to the U.S by the 11th you'll be fine
that's not accurate uh migrants without
documentation won't be able to leave the
city and those encountered by the border
patrol still are subject to title 42 and
after the 11th many will face Swift
removal if they're not eligible for
Asylum processes here in the U.S
okay
Montana 42 does expire the US government
will go back to process
eight with that comes Swift removal for
those who don't qualify for Asylum and
the possibility of bans on returning to
the United States for up to five years
in criminal charges a felony if folks do
come back
this latest search of migrants here in
the city of El Paso mirrors when
experienced in December the last time
Tada 42 was set to expire the difference
now local officials tell me is there's
more people
we figure that's anywhere between 10 to
12 000 people that are ready to come on
May 11th May 12th we do know that
there's additional coming right behind
them
right now in the background across the
city of El Paso officials are building
out shelter capacity they're preparing a
pair of decommissioned schools to
eventually house several hundred if not
more migrants expected in the area in
the coming days
[Music]